[Music]
I'm joined by three other players to
play the anthem demo I have never met
them before the game is going to force
us to play together if you don't rely on
your team you will probably fail at the
game watch me do this I am very excited
to see how this turns out
this is gonna be interesting I want to
jump into the game
so guys here we go again and I would
like to play some more missions if you
want to do we want to switch up the
difficulty because I closes on and so
like it
so you'll with me on it yes I think we
might have to be a little bit more
teamwork focus but okay if that's the
point right let's do that
well we Mathias wants his manifold I
don't know how big is a manifold I
didn't see what we picked up with is
hello hello hello oh wow he needed it to
fix his copy machine yes okay that's we
can print in color now it's gonna be
awesome
finally so mad there okay hit that
switch all right push the button there
is this tried-and-true technique never
fails - oh I'm gonna throw this out
there that maybe he shouldn't have done
the manifold divided you I don't like
this physical who's the real one
yeah look one any information will help
wait he's taking this information very
well we're doing three of them stay out
of trouble troubles my middle name
no all right it's Errol guys alright
Matthias you stay here and talk amongst
yourselves
but I like you me alright alright are
you guys ready to go and let's go
alright so I do wanna you wanna lead us
on this mission
yeah of course just return to through in
life with these
so I guess we're looking for threes of
things right yeah I'm gonna leave these
rabbits alone feel bad about earlier
tunnel you guys gonna go to the spooky
tunnel things happen in spooky tunnels
wait a second maybe we have a problem
here they're good tasty their cocoons
eggs always mean safety I mean what
irresponsible parent would leave eggs in
a dangerous place
oh there are things in the eggs first
we're fishin and blow up the eggs yeah
okay yeah it was nasty
watch out team it seems that some of
them actually kind of explode in a big
acid II ball I just love this I wake up
this yeah double grenade I'm gonna do
this close combat thing
the music well they're definitely taking
more bullets yeah oh yeah that's a
serious tougher bugs alright so why did
why did Matthias send this to this
horrible place we're supposed to
investigate and just well I think we
need to find out exactly why he is now
three people how you go about finding
out how someone turned into three people
I really need to talk tricky question
eliminate scorpion thirsteth go up in
yeah yeah yeah they're on the map
let's fly around and find him they're
not on the map but under like compass
yeah there's some nasty bugs
oh you found him well done oh this one
yeah oh um acid everywhere that's fine
it kind of all just kicked off there if
anyone's got any alts oh it wouldn't be
the worst time to use it
wait a little good choose the quiver
they gots to Oh
remember you can fly yeah yeah nice one
guys let's go down there some kind of
goo did she say you have to go down yeah
is that a scientific term yes I don't
like this guy's or it could be up yeah
thanks oh yeah oh ok hit my head oh you
got it samples collected ok yeah I got
the one over here I'm picking one up
over here as well should we shoot them
everybody gets a goo everyone's scoop up
some guru put it in your pockets yes
it's great for the machinery just stick
it in there forever
yeah just watched you doing this thing
so we're just picking up slime from the
floor and giving it to the class we got
you the slime that's nice
eat it it's good here my thighs the
slime you wanted yes it's a medicine
pharmacy ask a Runa call at the guell
park
Oh God blue for an egg I think if you
can skim the water just like that you
can keep your temperature down
it's kind of hard though because if you
go too low you just crash land okay
totally wacks that's given their enemies
oh okay guys wait for me I overheated oh
well we're definitely gonna have to
shoot some stuff so we'll wait for you
all right I'm coming let's go
geniuses like just leave rowing his way
and yeah we're gonna need to use some
teamwork here I think yeah okay okay all
right I'm gonna go revive that down guy
in the middle I've gotta go bravery
bravery fast oh okay nice anyone left
good good don't know this move yeah
I thought that was one of you guys going
push come back
oh whoa okay the peppy mg's OOP okay
that's strong there it is
or nope not on my watch oh that's a big
guy behind you okay guys all right uh-oh
Annie's got a flamethrower oh there's
another one okay really glad I just use
my my alts on the little guys shoot the
tanks on the big guys backs oh yeah yeah
they got little tanks so sure that
they're shut door tank just want to try
and get behind them and I'll try to
drill for words I think I'm gonna so if
anyone can get in ultra get in behind
them then you get a shot at those tanks
yeah that's one down yeah
his problem was cowardice genius I keep
thinking you're one of the bad guys guys
are ready yeah I don't know that's the
smart color scheme in this game the
minutes I spend shooting I do our job
let's go up in the sky a good job
destroying the three four big ones
nice I'm some teamwork we did it we did
it it sounds weird but we did it well
we're in the respawn restricted area
which means it's about to get real I
think
oh this is big big shoe guys
oh where is he he's um ah
chemistry me enough to me actually
actually he's just next time I'm coming
it oh there he is yet yeah so I'm here
it so I come behind nice one
wait I'm gonna I'm gonna cross oh no you
put us you oh oh ok for the tanks on the
back room okay we got it we got a big oh
nice
there it is yeah okay
back help
oh yeah get my salt I think we just back
to back to a couple of them that's again
looking really good
yeah there it is what's that for old sir
boss fight right after this with the
save
oh oh wait it that's team hard and fast
don't worry we're never gonna pick a
team name are we oh yeah let's plenty
over here oh yeah okay we're making
pretty quick work of this like we're
behaving ourselves
I think we're getting good yes I said
good well not bad I wouldn't go that far
we're not bad sorry I got ahead we're
being we're being less terrible yeah all
right I think we can free these guys
[Music]
told us to bring a GU what's this stuff
we found it on the ground so all right
so we've got a knee marker okay so we're
gonna stop the kidnapper
Ascari before it does more harm it
scurry scurry
oh yeah restricted area oh oh oh there's
wait oh he's in all that oh we probably
should have saved it one ultimate okay
oh yeah he's you but used to terrain you
know
I wants to say something about vertical
games there until next meet
all right maybe shoot some little guys
and stay behind cover him we have yet to
scratch this guy this is a should be
first cut the little guys oh yeah that's
probably worried about little guys
whistle all right
yeah they're gonna sponge up a lot of a
lot of our damage oh I got the old you
want to yo guys oh oh yeah I'm about to
die where were you oh oh it's getting
very real very quickly good watch out
for that super laser oh this is getting
messy let him put some health Oh found
found some found something all right
do you like that you can just kind of
fly away when necessary we didn't reason
oh I am down to a sliver sliver oh
they're all sort of spawning in this
belly back there ah that's a respawn
okay he's oh oh that that definitely was
the the first complete falling apart of
the teamwork there what is that oh yes
something is really hammering us oh boy
and I'm down we're okay okay it's big
medic I'm coming I'm coming good of
course it's just a test to see how
teamwork all right we did it we did it
we did it that's two snipers right by
the big tank thing okay switch back to
easy there's also there's two heavies
over here as well this is good no way no
way one heavy come on fire not in a good
way
I'm here I'm actually all one person
shoot his back nice yes nice one it's a
health Oh way don't have to shoot him
because I'm down together sorry I'm good
I got jet although I'm being targeted oh
oh
Turner honorable get out of here run
okay not a good idea I'm gonna go back
all the tank things meeting is coming up
for us oh we are getting flanked bad
blanket okay Oh bad badly badly we uh
try communicating or something yes or
just or just panic there's a time
community - Nikki ah you gotta swing got
this all right max I'll try and draw him
if you can get to the tank oh wait no
you draw him I'll go for the tanks all
right
he's also got a tank on his arm yeah I
see it I see it I see it I see it I got
it now okay okay okay yes I need to get
out of here really quick
hold on sorry I'm dying I'm dying Oh God
it's all right yeah we got the big one
yes oh yeah we're yeah I'm coming here
max it's okay GUP mouth wait a second
yep okay okay so I think we're supposed
to take down that massive thing but it
really does sponge up a lot of damage
god I don't have any energy so we can
try and focus just on the thing we need
to kill
yeah he's halfway down but oh my god Oh
okay I'm dying in the bushes over here
where were you were you it makes I'm
Kelly max I'm coming thank you oh yeah
all right oh yeah this is tough
yeah maybe it's just a way to attack the
tank from from higher terrain do the
trick on Medicaid second
ah okay I'm down with my tank if anyone
came coming I'm trying to find some help
I can see you can see you Mac okay this
is a dangerous repair but thank you
thank you thank you getting a bit even
man behind and now Rob imparting oh no
no no have any of it take all right yeah
this is pretty tricky this is very
tricky
dammit
oh I'm down I'm down well you read where
you good I'm right by the giant tank
okay I got you under my skirt okay
I'm going back Oh some yeah thank you
for a nice yep look guys we gotta have
this we gotta win this he's almost dead
what was that balling with it oh my hmm
well you it uh sort of in the middle of
everything we have nope yep there's two
of us I'm actually sweating okay and you
real-life and now we're on fire and
dying okay that's one
well you get this Oh
okay that road runner can ignore
everything except the objective guy yeah
okay Wiki okay he's almost off the map
he's almost dead
I got ultimate just a second okay finish
him finish him guys I can finish him go
on to the close combat oh okay I
finished in close combat I'm down me too
wait a sec he's not dead okay I'm going
back side of that one of those pillars
well you ready I admire bravery for in
there hope man I didn't make you go all
the way up there I should probably go
hide oh this would be great with a
sniper
no come on these only a sliver of health
left come on thank you well done
I've got great news guys I have an alt
yes I'm working on it hold on let me get
in position
I'm so glad it's never good no sir
oh I'm burning like hell oh he's got
such a sliver of life left oh he seems
to be always just red easy aiming at you
yeah we got him he sounds sweet
all right oh wow do we have to clear all
the other guys or no hey red okay that
was normal yes I am legit out of breath
I'm so happy we didn't put I'm gonna
change on the way oh that was hard
Wow so it occurred to me that maybe the
reason that was incredibly difficult is
that we forgot to equip new gear we
should reach for a trade he's saying
that using guns was the later to win
that fight I think a little bit too
enthusiastic and headstrong and we
should probably slow down a lot it was I
was convinced that using elastic bands
on those guys was gonna be what did it
but uh all right I'm sure we head over
to the forge things like you know we can
crank up our gear there cuz we picked up
quite a lot of loot there and what an
upgrade let's go take a look so my
default loadout is level 31 which I feel
is ungood that's not uh that's not great
I didn't even have a second weapon I did
any of us I guess no no only one all
right in my shield reinforcement
increases man I'm up from 18 to 214 oh
wow well yeah that would have sold some
problems oh look at all these guns
sniper rifles shotguns assault rifles
yeah has a lot here okay so my my level
now is 74 so I think we're probably
that's more than double what we store 71
I'm kind of impressed we managed to
finish that yeah
probably would have been a little bit
quicker had we you know what our
relative like difficulty level we set
that on by going in completely unarmed
I'll say Grandmaster one
I'll take muscle one yeah okay so let's
let's finish this mission let splits you
know put this in the ground okay all
right we're ready to go yep good okay so
they want us to speak with Aruna in this
guard he's pretty cool oh wait here's a
Runa she's hanging out for just
arbitrarily by these stairs okay he's
not pretty reality decay
reality decay he's not pretty you back
where's the other one yeah that's what
how you asked myself
hey where's Sumner where's the manifold
final he was impatient he wanted to
pursue his own theory he took it you
know where he went he talked about
needing a drink maybe the bar it's a
start yeah it's a really nice bar nice
boy yeah I was gonna say ah freelancer
let me guess
looking for Matthias yes and one of them
he wanted a drink but wasn't allowed in
he's been banned from the premises for
months great so he's gone now what now
let's see some nur anywhere he might
still have his link on him connect us I
can sense the link but I can't seem to
make the connection but I can track him
got him he's by the forge
by the forge all right I'm catching up
with you guys you said something I was
here I don't see him alright so it kind
of sounds like we've got a rogue Matias
he's hijacked a javelin and gone on it
for a wonder let's see if we go find our
rogue Sumner okay gotta save the
Matthias is's even seeing the extra guns
like strapped to the back I'm feeling
more confident about our next our next
encounter
I feel like confidence is sort of what
hit us wrong last time maybe we should
be humble yeah it only works if you can
just skim across the top it's so cool
yeah this is what I meant unlike fighter
pilots do all day every day we're not
starving for no just go clear oh oh all
right let's go blow up some bad guys oh
yes I want that to test our gear oh hey
mines careful
oh I'm all about this laser the laser
alright this is pretty cool my weapons
cool too oh yes this is what we were
missing
yeah firepower there it is oh I got a a
gluey grenade stick the grenade I didn't
change my grenade oh he's dead
oh yes I can feel the power
what's up the gluey oh there's a big guy
yeah I think we're gonna be okay
I go semi semi automatic oh yes
that thing sticks to armor I think yeah
it's good it's really cool
yeah nicely done right yeah yes so uh
upon closer inspection new gear does
help
well alright
all right I think this is going much
better guys even than the close range I
think guys we get we get stronger well
we're um we're not dying as quickly
that's for sure
yeah and that's a good thing all right
who's still hanging around there's this
guy over here nice one nice that wasn't
even a problem Oh crash the suit okay so
is he cruising around javelin free
probably not the best is exhibiting the
same confidence that screwed us hope
that he has his gear equipped yeah
there's some of those big dogs
so oh my gosh enemy stop oh yeah is
loads Oh guys they are oh I mean phrasal
yeah I'm coming guys yeah that's okay I
always go behind I like that these guys
exploded to goo that's pretty cool I
realized I was cheating you I'm sorry
well now we're gonna head in the cave ah
we're ready guys yeah well I feel so
manly
[Laughter]
finally
I love that there's there's no like
stealth here you're alive you're in a
while ago some that is so much since
isn't strange energy I don't know what
Sumner has the manifold with him he came
here for a reason so we can I don't know
if you guys are in the five five but we
can skip clean past it
whoa don't get electrocuted
oh love people I got too cocky okay
alright I'm on fire and dying huh well
yeah oh yeah there's a bug what's up I
thought you guys were here to win there
sorry okay that's a little better
you good all right is that it oh it's a
big guy good guy oh yes whoa all right
for me the answer Titan yeah apparently
that's how it's meant to go that well
done boys
slightly easier then we had a boy five
coins what was the highest difficulty
again
Grand Master three yeah and again we're
all playing the same class still because
we haven't unlocked the other ones
what's happening
[Music]
I think we found him
what's up Titans
this alright should we should we try and
take them out one at a time yeah
okay so here's some interesting
information
the shield does nothing for those
massive blaster fire energy okay so the
shield maybe use it sparingly or I think
it's more for projectiles rather than
specifically okay oh that one so let's
go back hey let's go back so yummy Oh Oh
No okay wait where are these guys oh I
am almost dead okay okay I got the
sniper staying behind got a little bit
of distance here okay yeah okay there's
where I where I am at the moment seems
to be oh wait no it isn't they can seem
to like bring these like fireballs that
spawn me I can't even get my favorite
protein okay so let's think you're some
hairy guy has anyone managed its
ultimate identify where the crypt points
are on these guys oh okay wait okay
let's see if we can find some creep
points say yeah I'm getting zero
I was getting literally getting zero
there ah whoa okay you almost got one
down
oh not easy
I got a snipe all right this guy's so
nearly done
he's so nearly done come on yeah okay
yes yeah he's done okay
Tex of energy oh I was died that was the
nice wall of fire okay all right we're
getting better at this yeah teamwork
okay so I can confirm the money that
laser that I've got does entirely
nothing against him unless I'm missing
some kind of like go and on my shield is
there any health anywhere that we know
of
okay yes my snipers pretty good but God
the damage they do damage Oh got to get
some shields back up yeah
are we you although health oh yeah oh
this guy's got really good aim yes ah
okay I have like no health this is bad
yeah wait a second
saber you sniping over there oh no I
actually brought a shotgun like a fool I
got sniper hey okay but trying to find
some like ground that's high enough to
stay above those fireballs oh I'm
burning in hell we got him the the
birding effecting your flying is pretty
impressive yeah yeah yeah how did he
know I was going there yeah pretty
clever guys they look stupid but they're
not oh okay
oh man way to get ultimate going on with
I got my ultimate but I've solo like oh
okay
so wait wait wait which guy you put the
ultimate on everything I got one I got
one yeah oh okay
ultimate on this one whoo they explode
though yeah yeah I got it oh you got it
are we down for last one yeah yep
everything on him everything Oh put them
put my shield
grenade everything he's almost done he's
almost done I'm trying to find these
critical damage areas okay coast on Beth
I'm going yeah okay I'm not going
I think we got this yeah I think we are
gonna take him down okay I seem to be
getting zero damage when I hit him from
the front like his chest seems mission
complete
yes yeah well done boys well done and I
said sorry teamwork
hmm I mean it was still tough but uh
yeah it was very intense new gear
ooh and we get new javelins unlocks
there's my javelina yes
yes okay I I think Matias is actually
gonna be okay I think we've done some
good work here
Leif nice nice nice fatty yourselves but
the best part is to be honest guys we
are level 12 yeah and we have now to
choose our new chaplains and that's the
part I'm most excited about I'm gonna
call some girls it
hello you look so good
[Music]